thank you so much for joining us here at
11 i'm denise feldas and i'm brian
loftis covet case is also impacting
student athletes foothill high school
announcing a major game cancellation
this week because some football players
tested positive but now some are
questioning how that decision was made
orco man is in henderson tonight after
digging for some answers
on thursday night the football field
here at foothill high school will be
empty just like it is right now the game
was canceled after some jv and varsity
players tested positive for covet 19 and
parents are frustrated i'm completely
devastated these kids put in a lot of
work cole reed's son is a senior on
foothill high school's varsity football
team but because some players tested
positive for kovitt during their weekly
test his thursday night lights game is
canceled this was their televised game
and it's against their rivalry basic
it's huge and now that game is gone in
this email sent to parents wednesday
foothill high's principal announced the
cancellation calling it a difficult
decision the policy is
flawed extremely brian forrest one of
the varsity coaches tells me the system
in place right now for ccsd athletes and
covid is unorganized if we're no one's
holding it accountable it's just kind of
it seems like we're just winging it
and the kids are suffering and it's just
not fair to them we reached out to ccsd
for clarification on who makes the
ultimate decision to cancel an athletic
game due to covid the district or the
school we also asked if there's a
certain percentage of positive cases on
a team that would lead to a cancellation
some school board trustees got back to
us and said these were quote operational
questions and they didn't have answers
to share with us reed says he just wants
transparency especially after last year
we can't allow them to take two seasons
away we just can't foothill high school
says the band cheer and dance teams will
also not perform this week reporting in
henderson orco mana 8 news now